[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: The San
Francisco fog is clearing,
making room for a cloud--
Google Cloud's
fourth annual event,
where thousands of
attendees have traveled
from around the world
to learn, collaborate,
and build a cloud for everyone.
Welcome to Next 2019
in San Francisco.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us
on the "Next Live Show."
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
If you can't be here
in person this week,
we've got you covered.
To make sure you
catch everything,
we have six Livestream
channels, including this one--
The "Next Live Show."
Let's kick things off with
insights on this morning's
keynote from Google Cloud
leaders, Aparna Sinha, group
product manager, Kubernetes,
and Quentin Hardy,
head of editorial.
Great to see you both.
APARNA SINHA: Thanks
for having us.
QUENTIN HARDY: Good to be here.
STEPHANIE WONG: Quentin,
we were just here together
nine months ago talking about
the state of cloud computing.
And that wasn't very long ago.
What have you seen
that's changed?
QUENTIN HARDY: That's
cloud time for you.
Nine months equals a year.
And two things stick out.
One, obviously new leadership.
We have a new leader
at Google Cloud.
And the first keynote
is very telling.
He's focused on customer ready,
enterprise ready, products
and services and
a wealth of them,
and customer testimonials
backing that up,
which is fun to see.
The other thing is the products.
A wealth of products.
A year's worth of
products in nine months.
I'd like to just
cite one of them--
the Cloud Services Platform,
which is now called Anthos.
Last summer when it was
launched, it was prospective.
It was going to be an alpha
and then beta very rapidly.
It's ready in nine months with
more features and products
and services within it
than we could imagine
having done this quickly.
Yay to your team!
And what this allows is for you
to create, deploy, update, run,
check, secure, all
these applications
on-prem in Google Cloud on all
the clouds, wherever you want.
Just take the asset
and make it grow
and make it live
better in a system that
is open and secure and
aimed at customer needs.
RETO MEIER: Now, Aparna,
you've been closely involved
in the creation of the
Cloud Services Platform,
or Anthos now.
Based on what TK's already
shared, it already does a lot.
Right?
But it's going to do even more.
So what will that look like?
And why should that
matter to our customers?
Yeah.
Well, know great computing
platforms don't just
add features or reduce cost.
Great computing
platforms actually
change the game entirely.
They give customers capabilities
that they've not had before.
And that's what Anthos is.
Anthos can be used even if
you're not in the cloud.
So it can be used in
your on-prem data center
to give you a cloud-like
environment, cloud-like agility
and speed, but also cloud-like
control and centralized risk
management.
And it gives both your
operators and your developers
a level of visibility--
operational visibility--
as well as ease of
use for the developer that is
hard to find anywhere else.
And then if you do
decide that you're
going to use a
public cloud, Anthos
gives you what no one ask
gives you, which is choice.
And it allows you to write
once and deploy your services
anywhere.
And that's what really
accelerates your business
success.
QUENTIN HARDY:
The reason we like
open systems-- yes,
it's a better way
to make more secure software.
It's better choice.
You get more velocity.
These are all great advantages.
There's an element
of self-interest
here, too, though.
By leaving it up
to the customer,
by giving them that
freedom and choice,
it compels us to
stay competitive.
We have to listen more closely.
We have to respond more quickly.
And if you have
locked-in customers,
it's kind of a recipe
for mediocrity.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah.
I think one of the things
that a lot of customers
like about the
cloud is that they
don't have to worry
about all of the things.
They can focus on
the things that
are important to
them and things that
add value to their business.
So for example,
developers and engineers
can focus on differentiated
capabilities that are unique.
And the cloud takes
care of all the rest.
But why only in the cloud?
You know, this is
something that you
want to be able to
do on-prem as well.
And that's what Anthos does.
It dissolves the layers that are
underneath the differentiating
pieces.
And those are managed by cloud--
by Google Cloud-- or they're
managed automatically.
And that way your business can
focus on accelerating itself.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
It seems like it's
picking the workflows that
makes sense for our customers.
Quentin, you mentioned
before we started
that modernizing and migrating
was another big keynote
takeaway.
How does Google Cloud's
integration with
and migration of enterprise
systems help our customers?
QUENTIN HARDY: Exactly what
Aparna was just saying.
Why can't it do more?
And in this case, why
can't your data do more?
Why can't all that
hard work that people
established over decades--
learning their customers,
learning their market,
learning their products,
be taken to the cloud
or be empowered inside on-prem
systems and get new life,
get new power, find new
insights with ML and AI
or by employing
other cloud services,
just refreshing all that
and taking that legacy
and using that as an insight
to move into the future.
STEPHANIE WONG: Speaking
of this focus on our users,
Quentin, what do
you think are some
of the most compelling
examples of learnings
that come with working
with our customers?
QUENTIN HARDY: You know
what's easy to do in tech?
Deliver a lot of complexity.
And some companies
love complexity
because it's kind
of like lock-in.
If you can get somebody to
learn all that complexity,
they'll never learn
anything else.
They'll be afraid.
You know what's hard?
Simplicity.
Simplicity on the back
end for the provider
is really tough,
because you've got
to consider a lot
of use cases, you've
got to build in a
way that's going
to work for a lot of
different interests and people
and locations.
That requires a lot
of careful thought.
And you've got to have a
kind of empathy for what
the customer wants to do.
What does the
customer wants to do?
The customer wants to do
the things it's good at.
The customer-- he or
she-- wants to proceed
with the things they've
learned in the market,
with the products
they're passionate about.
That might not actually
be container management.
That's something we're
passionate about.
That's something we do.
And in some ways this
is economics 101.
Let everybody focus on
their comparative advantage.
We are freeing up customers.
We are giving them
that simplicity
so they can get
stuff out of the way
and just work on the problems
to serve their customers.
RETO MEIER: Aparna,
Quentin has been talking
a lot about business folks.
But what does this mean for the
operators and the developers
are going to be using
this technology?
APARNA SINHA: Yeah.
Well, like I said, it's a
game-changer for the operators
and the developers.
I would say there are
three kind of big changes.
Number one is the right
ones deploy anywhere.
For developers it
means that you can
focus on the things
that add differentiation
to your business.
For the CIO it means,
actually, that you can really
concentrate your talent.
You don't fragment your talent
across multiple different code
bases, across multiple
different types of tools.
And if you think about it,
every customer I've talked to
always says, the talent is
the most scarce resource.
Particularly engineering
talent is really hard to hire.
It's really hard to keep
the talent motivated.
And I think the reason creators
are excited about an Anthos is,
again, for the same reasons.
Right?
Because they also get access
to a multi-cloud platform.
They also get access to the
benefits of something that's
at a level that they can
differentiate their code
and don't have to worry about
the underlying infrastructure
pieces.
STEPHANIE WONG: Quentin,
Google CEO Sundar Pichai,
was an important part of
the day one keynote as well.
What did his presence
say about how
Google sees the cloud industry?
QUENTIN HARDY:
Well, obviously, you
bring out the CEO of Google,
he's putting the stamp on it
that this is big.
And you can't say that enough.
And this gets kind of to an
abstract reality of where
we are right now in the world.
There are four major players,
five, you could go to six.
$5 to $10 billion in capex each.
This is a very big
stakes operation
because this is the
infrastructure of the future.
As much as you think
about airports or highways
or deep water ports or
telephones and telegraphs
in their time, this is the
infrastructure of the future
that we are building and our
competitors are building.
We're building it with a certain
spirit we've talked about today
we think will give the
customers the most power,
give individuals of any size--
small company, large company,
freelancer, you name it--
greater energy, greater
power, greater freedom
to realize what they
want to do in the world.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank you
so much for joining us again
and sharing your insights.
QUENTIN HARDY: It's
great to be here.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you.
Thanks for having us.
STEPHANIE WONG: We've-- only
just begun the first day here
at Next '19 San Francisco, and
there's still so much coming
your way.
RETO MEIER: As we
mentioned earlier,
we have six
Livestream channels--
Build, Run, Analyze
and Learn, Secure,
Collaborate, and of course,
the "Next Live Show."
STEPHANIE WONG: We'll have
product demos; handpicked
bite-sized breakout
sessions for you to watch,
which we're calling dev
bytes; as well as interviews
with Google experts and more.
Visit g.co/nextonair to see
the full program schedule.
RETO MEIER: And join the
Google Cloud conversation using
#googleNext19 across
our social channels.
And be sure to keep
the "Next Live Show"
streaming throughout the day
so you don't miss a thing.
STEPHANIE WONG: Coming up
on the "Next Live Show,"
our fellow developer
advocate, Kelsey Hightower,
will join us to share his
thoughts on Anthos and server
list.
Keep streaming, and we'll see
you after this short break.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Welcome back
to the "Next Live Show."
As promised, fellow developer
advocate Kelsey Hightower
is here to join us.
Thanks for being here, Kelsey.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I'm happy to be here.
STEPHANIE WONG: So earlier
we heard TK's keynote.
What are you most excited about?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Well, given
my background in Kubernetes,
I'm most excited
about Anthos, which
is kind of giving
Kubernetes to more
people and their environments.
So you can run it on prem.
You can run it on Google Cloud.
Also like the
addition of istio, so
giving people the ability to
manage their networking playing
like they do for their compute.
And I think the other thing
I'm most happy about is more
and managed databases.
So now having SQL Server,
lots of our customers
ask for SQL Server.
So pairing managed databases
with something like Kubernetes
is kind of a perfect match.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And Google has a
really strong tradition
of developer teams passing on
creative software innovations
to our emerging
developer audiences.
What tools can you tell
us about that are also
empowering our enterprise
developers with years
of experience and
proprietary systems?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
I think for the biggest thing
is like meeting developers
where they are.
So kind of integrating
with their IDEs,
giving them familiar
open source technologies.
So a lot of developers are
running things like Dock
or Kubernetes on their laptop.
Envoy packaged in Istio.
So what we're doing is taking
all of these open source
projects that you may be
using on your own machines,
or maybe even internally,
and we're just
adding a lot of
that support stuff
that you would need to run it
in production in the enterprise.
RETO MEIER: So we can see
that values are shifting up
the stack with higher
level sets of services
and new abstractions.
How is automation evolving
the developer experience?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Previously we've
been trying to automate
a lot of bad practices.
Right?
If you automate directly
on the virtual machine,
for example, now you're starting
to automate around scripts.
We had a lot of configuration
management tools,
but the APIs weren't there.
Now as you move up the
stack, things like Kubernetes
give us a declarative interface
for deploying on a distributed
system.
So containers, batch
drives, con jobs.
So now we sort of
think about automation.
You're finally targeting APIs.
So what we were able to do
for traditional software
development we're now able
to do for infrastructure.
So bringing things like
Istio, which gives you
a declarative API
for the networking,
things like our
serverless add-on give you
a declarative API for
your service stack.
So when you look
across the spectrum
now for infrastructure,
you're now programming finally
towards well-defined APIs.
STEPHANIE WONG: So this is
sort of supporting people
where they are.
And I want to talk about GKE
on prem and hybrid workloads.
What are some of
the benefits of it?
And what can sysadmins
kind of reap from that?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
I think since Kubernetes
came out, everyone was,
like, I want it.
Right?
And GKE, when you
click that button,
you just get this
magical cluster,
production-ready, ready to go.
And the next thing
is, well, what
about my existing environment?
And many people have
kind of tried to do it.
And not everyone has the same
level of expertise or time.
So the nice thing about
this is that we're
going to take GKE,
the same bits that we
used to host on GCP we're now
bringing that into your data
center.
So we're giving people clear
guidance on the lower level
requirements.
And then we just
layer GKE on top.
And then we give you the same
APIs, the same control planes.
So if you're using things
like Terraform on GCP,
you're now able to point
that same stack in your
on prem environment, get
that same workflow that you
love so much on GKE.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Kubernetes is being
adopted and adapted
to meet more and
more technical needs.
Tell us about how GKE Hub helps
admins with hybrid environments
do their jobs better.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
So GKE Hub. so once you kind
of get a taste of Kubernetes,
the next thing is you want
Kubernetes everywhere.
Right?
Every problem you see, you want
to rub Kubernetes on top of it.
So a lot of our customers
have more than one cluster.
If you think about it,
a lot of our customers,
they value high availability.
They'll have a cluster
per region or per zone.
So once you start to have
a collection of clusters,
even you bring an on
prem into the mix,
you need a place to aggregate
all of those things.
So what GKE Hub
represents is the ability
to aggregate all of your
Kubernetes clusters,
even the ones on prem.
And then once you have that
you have a centralized place
to do things like
policy management.
So once you have a
Kubernetes cluster,
the thing you have
to think about
is security across
all those clusters.
And one thing that's kind
of hard or error-prone
is you have to try
to figure out how
to get your configuration
correct across all
of those clusters.
So the Hub is going to
be the anchor point where
we build a lot of those
additional tools that
allow you to manage everything
from a central place.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Well, thanks Kelsey.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Awesome.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Right.
Now if you have more questions
for Kelsey or a comment about
the GKE On Prem talk, reach
out to us on social media using
the #GoogleNext19, and
we'll try to answer some
of your questions
during the show.
And of course, we'll
see Kelsey back
here in about an hour
to talk server solutions
for developers.
STEPHANIE WONG: But right
now let's talk about perks.
When you watch the
"Next Live Show"
you'll get exclusive
access to some sessions
only available to
Livestream viewers
that we're calling DevBytes.
RETO MEIER: So grab a notebook
and enjoy the first DevByte
on Anthos, originally
known as CSP.
Find out how you can leverage
GKE on prem and the Anthos
product suite to manage a
true hybrid environment.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Hi.
My name is Weston Hutchins.
And I'm a product
manager for GKE on prem.
Even with more
and more workloads
moving to the public
cloud, on prem software
remains a necessity for many
enterprise organizations.
Every enterprise
has apps that are
difficult to move to the
cloud or restrictions
on where sensitive
workloads can run.
Many are looking for
a true hybrid story--
one where they can modernize
the apps for the cloud,
but continue running in
their own data center.
Many companies have
looked to Kubernetes
to give them a
consistent environment
between on prem and cloud.
But getting started with
Kubernetes is challenging.
There are over 50 distributions.
And choosing the right
tools to install Kubernetes
can prove daunting.
And then once you
get a cluster up
and running, you enter the
land of day 2 operations,
where you not only
need tooling, but
considerable operational
expertise to manage the life
cycle of a Kubernetes cluster.
We find a lot of
customers that start down
the route of building
their own in-house DIY
tooling to manage Kubernetes
later struggled to keep
that tooling up-to-date.
Google's answer for hybrid
is Cloud Services Platform,
a stack that takes the best of
cloud native open technologies
like Kubernetes and Istio,
and lets you run them
in your data center.
But the key benefit of
CSP is the collection
of cloud services
that integrate your
on prem and cloud workloads into
a single unified experience.
Services like binary
authorization for security,
unified log-in and monitoring
through Stackdriver,
or centralized policy management
that syncs access controls
across all of your clusters.
At Next '19 we'll deep dive
into the infrastructure
layer for CSP GKE on-prem.
GKE on-prem takes all of
the technology behind GKE
and installs it on top of
VMware in your data center.
Once installed, you
register your cluster
with Google's cloud console
to give your administrators
and developers a single
pane of glass for managing
their clusters and apps.
In our talk at Next we'll
take a detailed look
into a real world use case.
Arctiq, one of our CSP
solution providers,
recently rolled out GKE on-prem
to one of their customers--
Optiva, a telecommunications
services company.
We'll walk through
Optiva's architecture,
show how GKE on-prem integrated
with their existing tools
and workflows, and gives some
tips for your own installation
of GKE on-prem.
Check out the breakout
session online.
And we'll get you up and running
with GKE on-prem in no time.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
Stick around.
The next session
will begin shortly.
Remember to check out
the five other channels
for curated content on Build,
Run, Analyze and Learn,
Secure, and Collaborate.
And after the session,
Kelsey Hightower
returns to talk about serverless
solutions for our developers.
See you back here in an hour.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome back to the
"Next Live Show."
RETO MEIER: We couldn't
get enough of him,
so we brought him back.
Joining us once more is Kelsey
Hightower, developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
Kelsey, talk to us about
how serverless solutions
help developers.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
I think serverless solutions
for people new to serverless,
it's kind of like we've
learned a lot of patterns
from four or five
years of Kubernetes.
And all the things you need to
do to provide that higher level
interface that you give
all your developers
or that you enjoy working
with every day, that's where
serverless attempts to start.
So we take some
of those patterns,
and we give people the smallest
interface that they want to do.
So if you think about it, if a
file gets uploaded to a Google
Cloud Storage bucket, you can
just invoke your business logic
and execute your code for you.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now
people want serverless,
but they also want containers.
How is Google
enabling developers
to have both the
velocity of serverless
and the flexibility
of containers?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
That's the thins
that I'm probably
the most proud of.
So when serverless was first
introduced to most people,
they always thought about it
as functions as a service.
You write a single
function, an event
comes in, it calls
your function.
But there's a lot
of existing business
logic that needs
a little bit more
than just a single function.
Maybe there's some
bootstrapping code.
You got to set up
things like logging,
but a little bit
more flexibility
and your choice of runtime.
So what we decided to do was
take a lot of the learnings
from Kubernetes and allow
developers to deploy
their own docker container.
So any runtime that you want
to use, any business logic
that you want, any
libraries, and we're
going to execute that container
just like we do with our Cloud
Function.
So they scale to zero.
They scale up quick.
And they give you the
same serverless workflow
that you're used to without
abandoning all the good things
that come with containers.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
You've talked a little bit
about serverless and brand new.
But we're changing the way
that we're approaching it.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about how Google is changing
that serverless experience?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So I think for
us is that our DNA has always
been around this idea of this
kind of software delivery
chain.
Right?
So this idea that when
you build a software,
we like to build it once.
We sign those images.
And then we decide where we
want them to be deployed.
So that means giving
people a bit of choice.
So typically, serverless has
been these proprietary cloud
platforms.
Once you're in there,
you're kind of locked in.
What we decided to do is make
sure that it runs everywhere.
So wherever you as
a developer want
to run, just like most
Google tools and libraries,
we allow our serverless stack
to run wherever you are.
So I think what
we're doing different
here is taking some of the
things that worked well
in the Kubernetes space,
and combining them
with some of the
developer experiences
that we know that people are
looking for, and just combining
the two.
So flexibility without losing
the trade-offs and benefits
of going serverless.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's great.
So how does serverless--
our serverless offering--
help our developers?
And how is it different?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I think where it's
different is that you get
to use a familiar tool
chain that has been popularized
over the last couple of years.
Right?
So containers are
the way most people
think about having full control
over their own software.
Then to be able to
take that software
and outsource all of
the delivery, right?
So security, IM
integration, being
able to connect to things
like Spanner and BigQuery,
taking all of that kind of toil
away from you and just saying,
hey, check in your containers.
And we'll run them for you.
So what we're
trying to do is kind
of make it very seamless
from a developer.
Once you go from
idea to deploy, we're
just trying to give you
that same DCP experience
at the container level.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Now how do our service
offerings give developers
a more open and
portable offering
so that customers
can potentially
move their workloads around?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So
one thing-- the trend
that has been really
prevalent in GCP
is in Kubernetes we started
with docker, popular open source
container runtime.
And then we shipped in open
source project, Kubernetes,
which is the underlying
platform for GKE.
And then when we thought
about entering serverless.
So we've had App Engine for
it for almost 11 years now.
And we decided that--
what would we do?
We wanted to make App
Engine be more open.
So we decided to start
with the Knative project.
So Knative has a lot of
serverless components
you can think of as a
serverless tool kit--
things like builds,
a function framework.
And most of that stuff is
layered on top of Kubernetes.
So what we've done is
we've taken the best
parts of Kubernetes--
again, those design patterns
that we talked about.
How do I just run
my application?
We've abstracted that out into
a high level set of libraries
called Knative.
And there's a hosted
version we call Cloud Run.
And we also give you the ability
to run Cloud Run on top of GKE.
So the benefit
there is that if you
need to do some
machine learning,
you can take that
serverless workload
and run it on a specialized
VM with a GPU or TPU.
So you're no longer restricted
to just our serverless
runtime environments.
You now have the whole of
GCP opened up to you even
in the serverless context.
STEPHANIE WONG: You
touched on this a bit.
But a lot of our
customers tell us
that they have
custom requirements
like specific run times,
custom binaries, or workload
portability.
And more often
than not, they turn
to containers for an answer.
Can you talk about how our GKE
serverless add-on allows you
to bring service to containers?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
So when you think about it,
a lot of these abstractions
change over time.
We went from mainframe
to physical machines
to virtualization
to higher level
platforms like App Engine.
What we now have with the
container image, this ability
to build a code that you
want, use the runtime
that you want, any
version that you want.
And now that becomes
a portable bit.
You can run this on
a virtual machine.
You can run this on GKE.
You can run this on Cloud Run.
And can also run
it on App Engine.
So I think what a developer
gets is this ability
to truly write once and
deploy wherever they want.
RETO MEIER: Now,
while we believe
Google Cloud is a great place
to run all types of workloads,
some customers,
we know that they
need to run on premises
or across multiple clouds.
Right?
So tell us a little
bit more about Knative
and its role in
giving developers
the freedom to move stateless
containers pretty much
anywhere.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
So our contribution
to the ecosystem started
with maybe Kubernetes.
Right?
So Kubernetes over the four or
five years, you can see it now
it's deployed and offered by
every major cloud provider.
Lots of people are already
running in on-prem.
So it has wide adoption.
So our strategy of
layering Knative
on top of Kubernetes,
this allows us
to kind of reap those benefits.
So the tools that
you're familiar with,
we layer Knative on top.
So that gives us that
portability framework
underneath.
So no matter where
you're running,
whether it's on-prem, different
cloud provider, on GCP,
you can get the
same APIs, right.
So we talked earlier about
automating those APIs.
That's what
Kubernetes represents.
And I've always said this.
Kubernetes is a platform
for building platforms.
And we've chosen to build
our newest serverless
platforms on top of Kubernetes.
STEPHANIE WONG: Can you
talk a little bit more
about how Knative provides
eventing and integrating
events from Google or
third party services
so you can really extend
your applications?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So the big
thing to know about Knative--
it's not just Google's Project.
Right?
So now we have so
many contributors--
Red Hat, Cloud Foundry.
So a lot of the
things that we've
seen in the eventing space,
like what is an event?
How should we accept it?
A lot of those open protocols
like Cloud Events, all of that
supported inside Knative.
So Knative gives you
a couple of components
we call Knative serving.
Run my container, scale
it to 0, start it again
when a request comes in.
Then you have the
eventing piece.
So there's an event.
And what we wanted to do
is make an event portable.
So different cloud providers
have a different collection
of events, different
transports for events.
So what we wanted
to do is make sure
that the event framework
was very flexible.
If you want to
integrate with GitHub
or GCP or some other
service that you have
that you defined yourself,
that's also included.
So what we've done
is we've given
all of these framework pieces.
And what we've
done with Cloud Run
is we've kind of curated
the perfect stack for you.
RETO MEIER: Great.
And is there a
particular way in which
we're able to solve that
problem that you describe
of having all of
these things living
all of these different places?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
So I think for us is
Kubernetes is super flexible.
So what that flexibility
allows every cloud provider
to do their own integrations.
For example,
on-prem, we come out
of the gate integrating with
things like VMware and F5.
So we abstract away
some of the differences
between all of these platforms.
So that's what
Kubernetes' job is.
Once you have that
set of abstractions,
things like Knative
just sit on top
and naively assume that
those abstractions are there,
and that we can get on with
building those higher level
platforms.
So Kubernetes is a
huge part of this.
And the community has
been doing this work
for over four years
of abstracting them
where the difference is
between these cloud providers.
So whenever you
build on top of that,
we just inherit all
of those benefits.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
thank you so much, again,
for joining us today, Kelsey.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Awesome.
Thanks for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: If you
want to re-watch or share
our conversation with Kelsey
on serverless solutions
for developers,
visit g.co/nextonair.
RETO MEIER: Now we turn our
attention to the next DevByte.
Here's a detailed technical look
at networking design techniques
for running
applications at scale.
Check this out.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Like
many developers interested
in microservices, you start off
dabbling with Google Kubernetes
engine, our powerful cluster
manager and orchestration
system for running
your docker containers.
First you accept
all the defaults,
and then slowly start
modifying a few parameters
to support your application.
BOWEI DU: As you
spend more time,
your confidence increases.
More traffic and
mission-critical applications
move to GKE, which is great.
You will be able to benefit
from GKE's advanced cluster
management features.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Soon enough,
your cluster size gradually
starts increasing.
Things seems to be
going fine until one day
when you start hitting
scalability and manageability
issues that can often be
avoided by implementing
some key best practices
during cluster creation.
Over the next few
sections we'll be
covering some of
the best practices
features and designs
in GKE networking that
can help you scale and
manage your GKE footprint
as your business grows.
BOWEI DU: First, let's talk
about VPC native clusters.
As you know, Kubernetes mandates
direct pod-to-pod connectivity.
But there is more than
one way to achieve this.
By default, Kubernetes
uses static routes
for pod networking, which
requires Kubernetes control
plane to maintain these
routes to each node.
This comes at a scaling cost.
In GKE we give you the
option to create clusters
in VPC native mode,
which provides
container-native networking.
VPC native node is enabled
with a single click
and enables connectivity
between all the pods in your VPC
without the overhead
of route scaling.
The VPC control
panel automatically
manages routing setup for pods.
And the native integration of
container networking in the VPC
fabric improves scalability and
integration between Kubernetes
and other VPC features.
MAHESH NARAYANAN:
Kubernetes also
makes very liberal
use of IP addresses,
which simplifies the system
and makes it easier to use
and comprehend.
But on the flip side,
this makes IP management
a challenge for
Kubernetes deployment.
This is exacerbated
in a hybrid deployment
or where IPs are fragmented,
making IPs a scarce resource.
VPC native sources are
providing flexibility
in defining your cluster
skill requirements
upfront for resources like
pods, nodes, and services.
So instead of having 100
resources and thousands of IPs,
you can now have 100
resources and 128 IPs.
This allows for Kubernetes
to reduce its IP footprint,
thereby improving the
overall IP utilization.
BOWEI DU: VPC native clusters
also enable other enterprise
grade features.
For example, sharing
VPCs between projects,
IM enroll separation, providing
anti-spoofing security
in our SDN stack, and also
private clusters for cluster
isolation.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Apart
from scaling, security
is another criteria
that needs to be
considered in best practice.
Enterprise users
require a deployment
in which your
services and networks
are isolated and accessible
only within trusted boundaries.
GKE provides this
through private clusters.
Private clusters makes the local
node and the cluster master
accessible only within
the trusted boundaries.
Any unauthorized access
to your control plane
is set to default deny.
For your [INAUDIBLE]
use case in enterprise,
private cluster also provides
a walled garden access
to control plane to
private end points, which
is provisioned by the customer.
BOWEI DU: Another
best practice to be
aware of for
applications at scale
is how you expose your
services to the internet.
When you need to deploy
your applications,
you may start off using
a cluster-based ingress
controller, such as
Nginx or HAProxy.
This is really familiar
for a lot of us.
It's just a standard proxy that
you would run on your laptop.
You would then expose
your application
to the internet using a layer
4 Kubernetes service load
balancer.
However, when your
application scales up,
you will want to use the Google
Ingress implementation in GKE.
The GKE container native
ingress is a globally scalable,
low latency
distributed proxy layer
that supports many of
the built-in features
such as caching, authentication,
and DDoS protection.
You won't want to
fiddle with how many
instances of your proxies
to scale up to, or worry
about how to absorb an attack.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: In
addition, the Google Ingress
has built-in support for
container-native load balancing
using network endpoint groups.
This means that
the network traffic
will be balanced directly to
the container in your VPC,
skipping the order of bouncing
through the Kubernetes KUBE
proxy layer.
You'll also be able to
easily debug your traffic
as your connections no longer
need address translation
to get to their destination.
There are also other
subtle advantages
of using Google Ingress instead
of cluster-based controllers,
such as connection imbalance,
and accurate end-to-end health
checks for your back ends.
BOWEI DU: GKE he makes
the job of deploying
a scalable Kubernetes
much less daunting,
and offers many features that
allow you to future-proof
your deployment.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: We have only
scratched the surface here.
And there are many
other techniques
that helps in scalability and
manageability of your cluster.
Please attend the HYB 314
session at Next 2019 SF
to learn more about
these tools and tips.
RETO MEIER: Remember, you
can rewatch that DevByte
or the session in its entirety,
scalable and manageable,
deep dive into GKE, on
demand at g.co/nextonair.
But let's switch gears
now and talk about PayPal.
Most of us know
that PayPal provides
a global online payment system.
But what you might
not know is how
Google Cloud's artificial
intelligence and machine
learning gives
PayPal the ability
to provide enhanced, customized
experience to their customers
and merchants even faster.
Take a look.
SRI SHIVANANDA: Today,
we're seeing transformation
all around the world.
Data is exploding.
Consumer expectations
are changing.
As there's growth
in online commerce,
there is a huge need
to support that.
Unless actually you
change how you think,
you'll not be able to go
through this transformation.
Public cloud technologies
are no longer an if.
It's definitely
a matter of when.
We picked Google Cloud.
And that's made a
huge difference.
Developers must be artists.
They should focus on
painting great experiences
for the customers.
With Google Cloud
you now have systems
that are more reliable,
up all the time,
secure, and economically viable.
That means better productivity
for our engineers.
VIKRIM WATAVE: We have improved
the velocity for my developers.
Say I want 100 VMs now.
And in two minutes
those VMs are set up.
They are impacting my end
customers and consumers
and merchants
because now they are
getting the features faster.
And that's huge.
SRI SHIVANANDA: We
had to get way better
at leveraging our data.
The expertise that Google
had in machine learning
and artificial intelligence
was a key factor.
And now we can go down to
each individual merchant
and each individual consumer and
give them a catered experience.
VIKRIM WATAVE: PayPal is
not just a payments utility.
We are a company with a
larger purpose for humanity.
SRI SHIVANANDA:
Helping people who
did not have access to
services that you and I take
for granted, that's what we
are trying to do with payments.
Google Cloud is going
to allow us to take
our business to the next level.
And that is really exciting.
STEPHANIE WONG: It's
time for us to step away.
After the next
session, you'll want
to meet us back here
if you're considering
hybrid cloud for your work.
Hen Goldberg, Google Anthos
GKE engineering director,
will join us for a deep
dive on a skill that
is critical to any business
that demands developer velocity
and quality from GCP.
Stick around.
You're watching the "Next
Live Show" from San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi there and
thanks for joining us.
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
Many of us are reaching for
hybrid cloud nirvana, which
makes the workplace mobility
between on-premise and cloud
computing ideal for our work.
To help us navigate
through this we
welcome Chen Goldberg,
engineering director
for Google Cloud.
Nice to have you here.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Hi.
Thank you very much
for inviting me.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Now, hybrid cloud
is a common strategy
that businesses
look to modernize
while still supporting
their current applications.
How does Google Cloud approach
this particular challenge?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So
first of all, it's
important to understand why
customers want to modernize
and what they are
looking for that.
And the most important
thing is for them
in order to compete they have
to increase their developer
agility and help them
to be more focused.
And they really want
to take advantage
of the amazing capabilities
that are available in the cloud
and using new cloud services.
But they have to make a decision
and choice because they cannot
modernize everything at once.
That's one of their concerns.
The second thing
is that they also
have concerns from
regulations that requires
them to stay on-premises.
So from their perspective,
it is a reality
that hybrid is here to stay.
And they have to choose a
hybrid strategy in order
to modernize and
advance their business.
For us in Google
Cloud we understand
that we need to support our
customers in their journey.
And our goal is to
make sure that we
help them reduce the risk
instead of increasing the risk
in going through this journey.
And risks are coming
in different levels.
For example, not
fragmenting your talent
in line to create a consistent
experience everywhere,
and also really leveraging the
existing assets you have today.
So not asking them to buy
new hardware, for example,
but really blending in to
their existing environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: And how
does this truly differ
from other hybrid offerings?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Google puts the
user at first in the center.
And we understand
that our customers
appreciate to have choice.
They want to be able
to choose where they're
going to deploy their workloads,
what kind of tools to use,
which services to use.
And our goal is to make that
possible while reducing risk.
We do it by building our
platform based on open source
technologies, which are ensuring
that the workers are portable
and we're not locking them in.
And we're also now approaching
multi-cloud strategically
and giving consistent experience
wherever customers choose
to deploy their workloads.
RETO MEIER: That's amazing.
What components make up Anthos?
And how do those
components work together
to provide a really integrated
approach for our customers?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So Anthos
is an opinion platform
managed by Google.
In the foundation,
in the core of it,
we are using open
source technologies
originated by Google, like
Kubernetes, Istio, and Knative.
But this is not sufficient
for our customer
to manage their heterogenous
environments they have.
On top of that, we are building
in multi-cloud, multi-cluster
control plane that lets
our customers connect
to all of their
environments and manage them
in a consistent through
a single pane of glass.
We also give them tools to
manage policies and control
in all of those environments.
But not everything
is containerized.
And this is also about investing
with what they have today.
So on top of that, we are
creating a service management
platform which allows
them to connect
all those services regardless
of what the compute there is.
And on top of everything we
have an awesome marketplace
that allows us to provide
both first quality
and third-party applications
available in all
of those environments.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
you just mentioned
investing in what our customers
are already using today.
How can Anthos be used to
help them modernize in place?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So what we
hear from our customers
is that when they come and they
want to use new cloud services,
they have first to
qualify and make sure
that the cloud meets their bar.
Let's say they want to
use BigQuery or even GKE.
They need to go through this
specific process, usually
manual process, to
make sure they can
let their developers use it.
With GKE On-Prem they don't
need to go through that process,
because we bring this technology
into their data center.
And they know it meets the bar.
So that's actually the fastest
way for them to innovate.
RETO MEIER: That's great.
What about config
management with Anthos?
How can you write multi-cluster
policies right out of the box?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So
that's a great question.
I think that the number
one concern that CIOs have
is how they manage risk.
And specifically how
can they make sure
that they know who access what
resources, and making sure
that they know what policies
are applied everywhere.
And when you have more
and more environments,
you have to build
more and more tools
and have more
people manage that.
So Anthos config
management allows
you to manage those policies
from a centralized place.
And even if by accident
or by a malicious user,
someone is trying to
break that policy,
automatically we will
apply that policy
and bring that environment
back to be compliant.
STEPHANIE WONG: So more
environments, more tools.
Can you elaborate on what
we're doing to give users
the visibility they need so that
they can see what's happening
across all these environments?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
So we are leveraging
open APIs, which
allows us to actually integrate
with every environment,
wherever the user chooses.
And we are creating tools--
centralized tools--
in the control plane
that gives you
signals or monitoring
data from all of
those environments
in a consistent way.
And we're also leveraging
things like Knative.
We just announced Cloud
Run is beta to give
a simple and effective user
experience for developers,
again, to deploy to all
of those environments.
So when I think
about it, it's not
about portability of workloads.
But it's actually about
portability of skills.
Can my developers, can
my service operators,
use the same set of tools,
regardless of which environment
they want to use?
And by leveraging open
source technologies,
this is actually possible.
RETO MEIER: That's fantastic.
I'm curious.
How are customers
using Anthos today?
And what are some of the
more interesting use cases
that you may have come across?
CHEN GOLDBERG: I'm smiling
because ever since we've
announced back then it was
CSP eight months ago as alpha,
we've seen an overwhelming
excitement with our customers.
Over 1,000 customers showed
interest just during Next
to try out CSV Anthos.
And we see different
type of use cases.
So I would say for
someone like HSBC,
they were excited to give
their developers platform
on more than platform
without having
to go through all the
qualification and making sure
that the new environment means
that also they're doing both.
But they know that for
some of the work loads
they will have to stay on-prem.
We see other customers,
like [INAUDIBLE],,
for example, that are looking
to innovate both on-prem
and in the cloud and create
a consistent environment.
And maybe talking about
a customer like Key Bank.
So they're really excited
about the agility.
So really leveraging new
tools and making sure they
can deploy quickly in
other environments.
So different customers
see different use cases
to begin with.
But they're all very excited by
both agility and reducing risk.
RETO MEIER: Thanks,
Chen, for walking us
through the
possibilities of Anthos.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Thank
you for having me.
RETO MEIER: Of course.
Now, if you want to re-watch or
share Chen's interview or any
other content you've seen
on the "Next Live Show,"
check out g.co/nextonair.
And if you've got a
question or comment,
reach out to us on social
media using the #GoogleNext19.
STEPHANIE WONG: We have
another first look for you
on the "Next Live Show."
This next DevByte is all
about the tools developer
should know how to use in
order to drive productivity.
Take a look.
ANKIT MEHTA: GCP is a set
of solutions and products
that can help you solve your
toughest business challenges.
We have external
paying customers
that run businesses on our
platforms and at massive scale.
These customers expect
developer velocity and quality.
MITHRA RAJAH: We have
thousands of engineers
at Google building this platform
at all levels of the stack.
These engineers want a
seamless developer workflow,
deterministic signals,
insights, and velocity.
ANKIT MEHTA: It is GCP
engineering productivity team's
role to balance these two
dimensions between developer
velocity and quality.
For example, we deployed
GCP's console twice a week
to our users, and
with high quality.
Our goal is to establish
bi-weekly high quality releases
across GCP.
MITHRA RAJAH: At
Google, we have created
a set of guiding principles
that let us have both developer
velocity and quality.
We want to share these
principles and the tools that
are available to you
so you can accelerate
at the pace your users expect.
ANKIT MEHTA: While we
at Google initially
focused on test
engineering, over
a decade ago we started looking
at engineering productivity
holistically.
This gave us the
framework to achieve
the right balance between
developer velocity and quality.
MITHRA RAJAH: This
meant that in addition
to doing complex
qualification across systems,
we started focusing on tooling
and infrastructure that enabled
developers themselves to qualify
their code changes before they
commit them.
ANKIT MEHTA: This in
turn allows us not only
to catch bugs, but
prevent them too.
This changed the way
we built, qualified,
and deployed our applications.
And we started pushing the
boundaries of both developer
velocity and quality.
MITHRA RAJAH: We balance
developer velocity and quality
at Google and on GCP
through Project Help--
pH.
We track key metrics across
developer productivity,
release velocity, reliability,
and most importantly, quality.
We automatically
calculate a pH level
and aim to achieve a pH
level of 5 for all projects.
ANKIT MEHTA: Our
guiding principles
are driving test
health, avoiding
performance regressions,
and high quality automated
releases, all of which are
anchored in actionable metrics.
Let's zoom in on two of these--
driving test health and avoiding
performance regressions.
For driving test health we aim
for hermetic integration tests,
fast resubmits, and
elimination of test flakiness.
We have built a cloud
integration testing framework
internally that helps us
write test once, and run them
against any environment.
MITHRA RAJAH: We
enable developers
to catch performance issues
early in the development
process to avoid
performance regressions.
We have a framework
that enables developers
to create sustainable
performance automation that
can gate releases on
performance criteria.
And we aim to improve GCP's
quality and deployment
by reducing manual toil,
increasing automation,
eliminating cherry
picks, and improving
the fidelity of the test
signal in our pre-production
environments.
ANKIT MEHTA: Let's
dive deeper into what
we're doing for the
external developer and user.
Google works closely with the
external Kubernetes and Istio
developer communities to
enable developer productivity
and open source.
Kubernetes is an
open source system
for automating deployment,
scaling, and management
of containerized applications.
While Istio is an open
source service mesh
that provides traffic
management, policy enforcement,
and telemetric collection.
We are active contributors
to special interest
group, [INAUDIBLE]
testing, and Kubernetes.
MITHRA RAJAH: Some
of the tooling
we helped build in the open
source community includes prow,
the continuous integration
CI system used by Kubernetes
and a lot of other projects
that use Kubernetes.
prow is built on
top of Kubernetes.
So our CI helps test
Kubernetes on Kubernetes.
ANKIT MEHTA: Testgrid provides
a grid of test results,
making it easy to see
patterns over time,
provides fast access, and allows
interactive sorting, filtering,
grouping, and more.
It is highly configurable and
integrated with Cloud Build.
MITHRA RAJAH: Recently we
helped build hermetic testing
using Kubernetes and Docker.
Kind brings up a confirmed
Kubernetes cluster locally
without any external
dependencies
for testing Kubernetes
changes or integration testing
Kubernetes applications.
Kubernetes was designed
with portability
and interoperability in mind.
And providers want to enable
application portability.
Google, alongside
other cloud providers,
helps out with the Cloud
Native Computing Foundations
conformance program, which
ensures certified Kubernetes
products deliver
consistency and portability.
ANKIT MEHTA: The
outside world now
uses VMs, Kubernetes containers,
scalable storage, GitHub,
and so on.
Google's software is stored
in a single shared repository.
The developer landscape
is rapidly changing.
And we are evolving our
tooling and incorporating
external tooling to adapt
to this changing landscape.
Summarizing, we
believe that if you
prioritize driving test
health, three performance
as a first class citizen,
and have automated CI/CD that
enables high quality releases,
and measure everything--
MITHRA RAJAH: You can
have the same developer
velocity and quality as we do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Thanks, team.
If you want to share this
DevByte or watch the complete
session, check out Move
Fast and Don't Break Things
on g.co/nextonair.
At Google Cloud,
our customer stories
are truly inspiring to hear.
We take you to Indonesia now to
profile GO-JEK, a company that
uses Google Cloud to
not only scale quickly,
but to bring the marketplace
and millions of Indonesians
closer together.
RETO MEIER: It's
really inspiring
to see how GO-JEK has created
opportunities for people
across all of Indonesia.
All right.
Now it's time for the next
group of sessions to start.
Once they're finished,
join us back here
to learn how to develop for
Kubernetes without leaving
your IDE.
You're watching the "Next
Live Show" from San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hi.
I'm Stephanie Wong.
Welcome back to the
"Next Live Show."
It's only day one of Next, and
we've covered a ton of ground
already.
We started the day with
the opening keynote
followed by post keynote chats
with Google leaders and product
demos.
If you missed any of it, visit
g.co/nextonair to watch it all
on demand.
Now let's throw it
over to Mark who
has more information on our boot
camps and certification testing
taking place right
here at Next '19.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey.
I'm Mark, and I'm
here at the boot camp
section of Google
Cloud Next, where
we've got thousands of technical
practitioners and developers
here to learn a new skill or
get Google Cloud Certified.
Attendees can check out
trainings, take hands-on labs,
or get assessed for Google
Cloud certification.
Of course, each lifelong
learning journey
is a unique one.
So let's talk to
some of the folks
who have been Google
Cloud Certified.
THARA SAVIO: I chose to get a
Google Certified [INAUDIBLE]
wanted to have a very good
knowledge on Google Cloud,
also to have that confidence,
especially when you interact
with clients, or
even within a company
when you want to build the
system to have that confidence.
JIGAR NAVADIYA: I choose
Google Cloud certification
to gain the trust of my clients
that I had the technical skills
to build the best data
pipelines and the architectures
for their business requirements.
GREG LAZARUS: So I
chose to be certified
because there is a real
value for a certification
on the market.
Every company is really
looking for that.
And if you want to
work in the cloud,
you have to have certifications.
GIOTTO MASAWI: Part
of it was knowing
that the Google Cloud Platform
has been growing exponentially.
I thought this was the best
time to be well aligned
with such an environment
in technology
and get that certification
from Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
the certification process
doesn't stop there.
They're taking their
teachings back with them
to help their own teams start
on their learning journeys.
JIGAR NAVADIYA: From this
certification, right,
I wanted to gain more and more
learning from my fellow Google
Cloud Certified
team and Googlers
to learn more real
world use cases.
GIOTTO MASAWI: So part of
it has been career growth.
On my side there's been a huge
spike from the clients that
have been reaching out to me.
And I've also worked with
the team of about four
of my team members, and we
all dedicate a lot of time
to studying and learning
the whole Google Cloud
suite of products that they
have to make sure that we're
prepared for the certification.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hopefully this inspires
you to start your own learning
journey down Google Cloud
certification and seeing
what you can build.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thanks, Mark.
For more information on
becoming Google Cloud Certified,
be sure to visit
cloud.google.com/certification.
Joining me now is Priyanka
Vergadia, a customer engineer
at Google Cloud who's
going to show us
how to develop for Kubernetes
without leaving your IDE.
Thanks for being here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you for having me.
I'm going to talk about
Kubernetes and how developers
can work within
the Visual Studio
environment and deploy
applications into Kubernetes.
So let's jump right in.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Cool.
So I have on the left-hand
side my terminals
which we are going to use
to do some deployments.
And then on the right here
I have a Visual Studio Code.
So we're going to start off
by creating a new application.
Just create a hello
world, no GS application.
Nothing fancy.
So what's happening
here is we should
be able to see our
application created.
Once I refresh it is
showing up my application.
I have the source files.
The front end and the back
end are the different services
that are in this application.
In the front end, we
have the 8080 port that's
listening to the front end.
It's talking to the back end
on back end service address.
And in the back end
we have the index file
that's also talking to 8080.
So we're going to change
that to 8081 so that we
don't have a port conflict.
And then at this point, if we
go and start these services,
I'm gonna just check where
we are in our terminal.
We're at the right place
in the front end folder.
And we want to do the same
for our back end as well.
So I'm gonna go into
the right folder, which
is the hello world
no GS application 2.
And then so we are now in back
ends and front end folders.
Now if we run NPM
install, that's
going to get us all
the dependencies
that it needs to run both
our front end and back end
services.
And then once that is done, we
need to start these services.
So our back end is
running on 8081.
And our front end
is running on 8080.
So we're ready to
test our application.
Our back end is on 8081.
And our front end is on 8080,
talking to our back end.
So we have an application that's
running through Visual Studio
Code.
Now at this point, if I wanted
to deploy this application
into GKE, I would first
need a cluster to create.
And then once the first
cluster is created,
then I can start deploying
this application.
So let's see how we can create
a cluster from within Visual
Studio Code.
I have the extension
for Visual Studio
Code called GKE extension.
And once you download
that extension,
you'll start to
see your projects
and your clusters in
your ID environment.
I'm going to just use my current
one of the current projects
and create a cluster
in the current project.
So my current
project is KQ Demo.
And so we'll set
that as a project ID.
And then it gives me an
option to select the zones.
And then here we're just going
to say Test as a cluster name.
And then there's
the number of nodes
that you want to create
that you can change.
And then also the machine types.
We're just going to go with
the standard and click Create.
Once I do that, it takes
maybe three or four minutes
to actually create the cluster.
It's spinning up
all these instances
in Google Cloud for you.
And if I refresh
this, you should
be able to see that it's
starting to bring up the test
cluster right here.
It's orange, because
it's not set up yet.
So give it a few minutes,
and it starts to set up.
At this point we're going to
just use for the demo purposes
a cluster that I
already have created.
And we'll go through the
demo using that cluster.
Now, once I have the
cluster, I'm ready to deploy.
And I need a skaffold yaml to
actually deploy in the cluster.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
And for those who
might not have heard
of skaffold, what is that?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
skaffold is basically
a command line tool
that lets you define
your Kubernetes manifest.
It also defines the
container registries
for the back end
and the front end,
and especially for
our application here.
So if you have a large
number of services
that are running
on application, you
would define your Container
Registry addresses in there.
It would pick up
from those addresses
and deploy your service in GKE.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So let's see an example of that.
So I'm just first going
to go through deployment.
I think I forgot
to set the cluster.
So let's first set this cluster.
Once it is set, then
we're going to deploy.
Take the deploy and do that.
Starting to deploy.
While it's deploying, let's
look at our skaffold yaml.
This is the yaml I was
talking about where
you have the back
end and the front end
and the GCR.io addresses,
which is the Container Registry
address, and then the
manifest for your Kubernetes.
And it seems like we have
our application deployed.
So let's see the IP address.
That's the IP address
of our application.
It's the one that
we just created.
And we see that the application
is working on port 4,000.
So our front end is
talking to our back end.
Both of them now deployed
on a GKE cluster.
So we did all of
that from our IDI.
And yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's fantastic.
I guess the next step
that I would think of
is making changes to,
let's say, our back end
without affecting our front end.
So for example, what if I
want to test to make sure
that my change doesn't break
anything without needing
to redeploy and rebuild?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's a great point,
because in a
development lifecycle
that's the biggest hurdle.
You test, you develop, you test.
And then you want
to deploy that.
But the test stage is
a very critical stage.
So you would use something
called TelePresence for that.
And TelePresence is,
again, a command line tool
that helps you create a proxy.
So in this case in this
example, what we're going to do
is create a proxy and create
our end run, our back end,
on local machine.
And then our front
end would continue
to run on our GKE
cluster in production.
So we're able to test the
changes to our back end.
But our front end stays intact.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So let's see that.
Yeah.
So in this case here, so when
you come out of this, and let's
see where we are.
I want to go into
the application
that we just deployed,
which is this.
And let's make a
little bit of a change
here in our front
end application
so that we can use
a little bit of--
I just called it Version
2 for our back end.
And at this point, if I run
my TelePresence command,
which is nothing but--
it creates a proxy,
and it's going to
run it on port.
So here it is.
It's forwarding the ports now.
And if we go test our back
end on our local machine,
that's going to version 2.
And it should work the same
way from our front end as well.
So that's pretty
much how it works.
STEPHANIE WONG: Very impressive.
So we were not only
able to see you
being able to redeploy using
your local IDE to GKE, using
cloud code and skaffold,
but you were also
able to make changes locally
to a single service, test it,
and then, again, redeploy it
to GKE once we were using.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Pretty powerful.
Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
TelePresence.
OK.
Well, thank you so much
again for joining us.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's
send it over to Reto.
RETO MEIER: Thank you very
much, Priyanka and Stephanie.
Stick with us.
We're going to take you
to the showcase floor
where we'll see about
living a life of code.
You're watching the
"Next Live Show."
We'll be right back.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Welcome back
to the "Next Live Show."
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
We'll be here for all three
days of the conference,
sharing the Google Cloud
Next experience with you
wherever you are.
If you missed anything or want
to re-watch and share a video
you like, head to
g.co/nextonair.
While you're there, check
out our other five channels
organized by theme--
Build, Run, Analyze and Learn,
Secure, and Collaborate.
RETO MEIER: Now let's head
over to the showcase floor
where our reporter Natalie
is checking out the Cloud Run
demo.
NATALIE: Hi, everyone.
We're here at the Life
of Your Code demo.
And I'm joined here by Girija.
How are you?
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Good.
NATALIE: Good, thank you.
Tell us a little bit about what
you do and what you've made.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Awesome.
So I lead product marketing
here in Google Cloud
for our serverless products.
And we recently announced a
product called Cloud Run today.
And I'm really
excited about that.
NATALIE: Right.
Can you show us what it does?
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Super.
So I'm just going to
build a simple app.
And we're going to
get started here.
So what we're doing
right now is think
of the train as the app itself.
So we are going to
start by customizing it
first and building our
train, so building the app.
So adding different components
like compute, database,
and so on to the train;
building the train,
so it's checking for security
vulnerabilities and all
of those in the second step.
And then finally, we're
going to deploy it.
And we will be able to
see it on the big screen.
NATALIE: Awesome.
Let's get started.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Super.
So getting started here,
adding a train car first.
So the first thing
that we're going to add
is the engine itself.
So engine here is
the compute platform.
So let's start with the compute.
So Cloud Run is amazing,
because it enables the developer
to write apps in any
language they choose.
So for example,
with Node.js or C
Sharp Python are the
options we have here.
But really any language they can
choose to write their apps on,
and it's totally fine.
So I'm just going to
select a blue color here.
And then getting started.
So now that's our engine.
So we're going to add a
second train car here.
So now what we are doing is--
so this is a passenger carriage.
So what it's doing
is it's letting
us select our language in
terms of adding a Docker
file to the app itself.
So as a developer, if I'm a
Java developer, for example,
and the cloud vendor
doesn't support Java,
that's totally fine.
I can specify the Docker file.
And it's going to package
my app into a container.
And it's going to deploy it.
So that's what
we're seeing here.
So I'm going to select Go.
Let's do this colorful--
NATALIE: [INAUDIBLE].
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Yeah.
NATALIE: Yeah, that looks cool.
Little pica dots.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
And so finally
now what we're going to do
is add a database to it.
So this is a database
that I'm going to add,
because databases are
an essential component
of building an app.
So there are different
options that you
can add if you want
integrated with Cloud Run.
So we have a few options
here like MongoDB
or Redis or Postgres.
Really, it works with any of our
Google Cloud offerings as well.
So a lot of options
to choose from.
So let's select one of these.
A green color.
Let's go ahead.
NATALIE: Right.
So we've completed the build.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Yeah.
So now what we have
here is this is the app.
So think of it as
a developer writing
code for the entire app.
And they're ready to go.
As a developer, this is
all you will have to do,
which is core to
what they're doing.
They don't have to worry about
the infrastructure, scaling it
up and down, monitoring
it, managing it.
All of that has gone away.
NATALIE: Let's
focus on the code.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
Just the code.
Just focus on the code.
So now I'm going to
complete the build.
So now what it's doing is it's
pushing the code to Cloud Run.
So it's checking for
security vulnerabilities.
It's making sure the build
image-- the container
image-- is being created.
So now you can see the
scanning-- the security
scanning-- for the code
as well using Cloud Build.
And now all of this is complete.
We're going to give it a name.
NATALIE: That's your initials.
G S. Right.
Ta da.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Yeah.
So now we're going
to just deploy it.
This is the exciting part.
So the train is actually going
to be seen on the large screen
in just about a second now.
NATALIE: Awesome.
Oh, there it goes.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
That's the fun train.
So now what it's
doing is it's going
through the train
station of the QPS,
where it's getting
a ton of traffic.
So think of your app as a
lot of uses using your app.
So it's getting
a lot of traffic.
And Cloud Run will automatically
scale your app from zero,
literally, if there's no
traffic, to whatever instance
it needs, and then
bring it back down to 0
all just within seconds.
NATALIE: Wow.
That was a really
great demonstration.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
Thank you for having me.
NATALIE: And back to you.
STEPHANIE WONG: The
last sessions of the day
are coming up.
Be sure to tune back in to
the "Next Live Show" tomorrow
morning at 8:55 AM.
We kick off day two with a
product innovation keynote,
followed by an
exclusive interview
with Google Cloud's director
of AI strategy, Tracey Frey.
RETO MEIER: And remember, check
out our library of content from
Next '19 at g.co/nextonair.
STEPHANIE WONG: Stay tuned for
the last sessions of the day.
Have a great evening.
And Reto and I will see you
back on the "Next Live Show"
tomorrow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]